The joe rogan experience.
Look,
I live with the fact that there's some people that,
ah,
of what I do.
And then there are some people like,
I'm fucking baffled.
Why is this mother fucker still here?
So I get,
and I get like a,
I get that,
love it or leave it or love it or hate it.
Really.
I mean,
I'll take love it or leave it because that's a perfect example.
What you just use those a great example.
What's special about this whole thing is that a guy like you,
like you saying that,
uh,
you know,
that you're a love it or leave a guy.
But if you weren't,
you [inaudible] look,
if you weren't a guy who has his podcast sponsored by the flesh,
slide,
a guy who puts out a podcast in the Internet way before anybody and a guy whose
most recent movie you just said,
come off kind of fuck everybody.
I'm just going to do this on my own.
Do it written,
release it my way.
Fuck the entire system of it.
A guy like you really wouldn't exist any other way.
No.
You know,
it's kind of,
you've got to go.
You're the ultimate love it or leave your,
you're doing it your way.
Play it with passion.
Here's my philosophy and how does everybody's philosophy?
It's not even an original one.
One life.
You fucking die.
That's it.
And you don't know what's on the other side.
And we hope for this,
that we hope for Candyland.
Well,
we don't know.
It could be as simple as getting a box and stay there for all the fucking
attorney you had.
Your shot,
your computer,
we shut you down and you're finished.
So if that's the case,
it,
it behooves you to shoot for your dreams every time.
I know it sounds a little dopey and Tony Robbins this,
but it's real.
It's real.
Like in a world where you're going to fucking die.
Like this is the way I think about it and that it's an example that's a real
close to home.
My old man was a good dude,
my father,
good guy.
Not many good men in the world.
This was a good fucking guy did worked at a post office cancel and you're
fucking stamp.
What a soul killing,
horrible job that is for years just to pay for a fucking family.
Who knew if he had dreams.
Maybe his only dream was to like,
oh,
I'll get married and have kids work.
Maybe it wasn't a big deal to him.
And he did whatever he had to put food on the table and stuff like that.
Good Dude.
Take me to matinees every Wednesday.
Go see a movie,
take mass school half day,
go see flicks and whatnot.
Uh,
never know.
We're not one of these parents,
you know,
fucks around with a kid or something like that where you're like,
oh,
he was all good except there was that good straight arrow.
Fucking dude didn't went to church because his wife made him but wasn't big into
the church.
Fucking mode has mother-in-law's lawn all the time.
Good guy.
Raise three good kids or at least two good kids in me.
And so my father,
we'd go out to eat one night,
uh,
he's best 68 years old.
We'd go out to eat and Morton's in Philadelphia,
uh,
and is one of those special nights.
Man was like the old family winds up being the same place.
Hadn't been that way in years.
My Mom,
my dad,
me and my wife's with me,
uh,
my sister and her husband and she lives out in at this point I think she was
living in Kobe,
Japan or something like that.
So she's rarely back in the states and my brother,
he's married to do,
but his husband wasn't with us.
I didn't make the trip that time.
Unfortunately.
There we are in a back room at Morton's,
you know,
an Eaton having a great time chit chat and he'll mass putting away steak.
Cheesecake is,
I have a couple of Manhattans.
That was his fucking poison.
And you could tell,
and I don't even like paint this in retrospect,
it was clear on the night,
parents love seeing their kids all in one place.
Happy,
healthy,
not fucked in the head or something like that.
And you could tell he was enjoying it.
There were,
as kids shooting shit,
everyone's trying to make each other laugh at shit,
trying to make him laugh.
He,
everyone's,
since everyone's paying attention,
everyone else,
maybe nobody's paying attention to him meet and maybe too much cheesecake that
night,
but fuck it,
we're all having a good time.
Put them in a cab that,
and I kiss him on the head as like,
hey mousy in the morning.
And he'd come out to Philadelphia to see me do Q and a at the wizard comicon,
Philadelphia wizard comic come off,
he goes in the cab,
go home and I go to the hotel,
go to sleep.
I get a phone call at six in the morning from my brother and my brother's like,
um,
you got to get down to the hospital in Walnut.
And I said,
why?
He goes,
dad.
And now my father was in and out of poor health,
who's diabetic and whatnot.
He'd had like strokes,
heart attacks and stuff like that.
He,
yeah,
he was bad health dude.
But um,
but not so when my brother's like dad's in the hospital,
I'm like,
okay,
what now fucking throw a rock and dad's got it.
And my brother,
you could hear it in his voice.
He was just like,
you got to get down here right now.
And I was,
oh shit.
And I hung up,
got dressed,
went down.
I've get to the emergency room,
open the door.
First thing I see is my mother who looks more scared than I've ever seen,
a human being in my life.
Fucking terror on her face.
Not,
I've seen my mother cry in my lifetime.
You know,
I've made my mother cry in my lifetime.
I've watched her cry watching fucking Falcon Crest when I was a kid.
This was different.
This was like terror,
fear.
Uh,
you know,
almost like there was a fucking gun to her head and off of her face.
I looked in my brother and my brother just has this expression where you just
kind of gives me the slow nod,
which is,
he's gone,
you know,
my father was dead and I went in and I saw him on a Gurney and shit,
and it was so strange.
And I go outside and I was a smoker,
like cigarette smoke room.
Those days I was going to have a cigarette and,
uh,
Donald comes out and I was like,
oh,
uh,
this is a shock and whatever,
you know,
we're upset and stuff.
And uh,
I said,
how was it because he was there.
what happened?
And Donald tells me the story of like,
a dad woke up and had this like big reaction,
like just like,
I'm hot,
I'm hot under his,
thrown the sheets off and mom freak touches.
Like,
what's the matter?
What's the matter?
She told Donald Call,
I'd call the ambulance,
call the hospital,
and he was gone within seconds.
So that's a,
you know,
bad enough,
he was hot and uncomfortable.
You don't want to hear like,
oh,
he died in his sleep and we woke up and he just didn't.
But then my brother says,
this thing probably defined my life.
My brother goes,
uh,
he died screaming and I go,
what,
what?
And he goes,
he,
he died screaming.
And I was like,
w I mean as,
is that a figure of speech?
And he goes,
no,
he literally,
he died screaming.
And you could see my brother was haunted by it and my father wasn't like a,
I wouldn't say he was a butch man or strong man,
but he wasn't the soft men money stretch to the imagination.
And I never heard him get real loud or anything like that.
And the notion of my father dying,
screaming changed my life because I was like,
even a good man in this world.
You play the game,
you play it straight,
you play by the rules,
you do everything you're supposed to,
you're going to die screaming.
And at that point I was like,
there's no point in not trying to accomplish every stupid fucking dream I've
got.
Even if it's dumb shit,
like fucking,
you know,
Oh my God,
I've always wanted to collect this money.
Fucking a Wayne Gretzky cards in one fucking binder.
Or if it's like I want to make a movie or if it's like I want to put on podcasts
or I want to do a TV show now I want to write a book,
chase it all down.
Chasing whimsy is what I've been doing for the last few years,
just smoking weed.
And chances went whimsies anytime I'm like back in the day,
I'd have a good idea,
something I really wanted to follow through on it.
And they'll say,
you can get scared.
You start thinking about some about some of the fucker's gonna say and be like,
oh,
it's stupid.
Why would you fucking do that?
And fucking why?
Why?
A lot of why people in this world,
I try to surround myself with the why nots,
motherfucker sir.
You're like,
I want to try this.
Like why not?
Let's go,
let's give it a shot.
You gotta be game man.
People help you achieve your dreams and shit.
So for me,
the last few years I've just been trying to accomplish every dopey dream to big
shit.
The little shit you got to do them all.
You can't just do the climb every mountain shit.
You know,
he did sometimes late at bar down,
step over it and be like,
tonight,
Hasa,
you feel accomplished,
but chase it all and do it all because we're all gonna die screaming.
And you might as well enjoy it here and I,
and when I say chase all don't fucking do it at the expense of someone else.
Obviously don't hurt somebody else,
but go after your James Man.
If your dream is to like,
I want to kill 12 children.
I'm not saying I'm not talking to you,
but go after your dreams of not going to hurt anybody.
[inaudible].